You know,
one thing you're doing
that is great is you're staying sane
by doing a sort
of a live stream on Twitter.
Yeah.
And what's really nice is
that your fans,
you got a lot of fans they get to talk
to and they get to ask
you absurd questions.
And then you answer.
That is the best.
That is the best thing about it
because podcasts are great
and shows a great,
but there I think that there,
the audience is watching
other people talking
to each other,
whereas this I'm actually talking to them
and I'm answering their questions.
And some of the questions are really good.
In fact,
I want to do it live and use some
of their questions.
'Cause they're,
they range from really interesting
philosophical questions
to just ridiculous questions.
But it's, it's,
it's really good fun,
and you're right.
It keeps me sane and,
and it's free
and it's like a,
it's like a big sort of online club.
So I'm really enjoying that.
Yeah.
What kind of questions have you gotten
that you've really liked where fans have.
One question was they know I love sort
of science and nature and they said
what is the most amazing
fact about nature?
And that's really
because it makes you think
because it's so amazing.
My answer was,
humans are more closely related
to salmon than salmon are to sharks.
I didn't know that.
So show the,
it's the vastness that the length of time,
the number of generations
in evolution and.
And then someone asked me,
would I rather have thumbs
for nipples or nipples for thumbs?
So what's your answer?
I said,
I'd rather have thumbs for nipples
because then I could hitchhike
while reading a book.
(men laughing)
I think I want the nipples on the thumbs.
I want, I want nipples.
Really?
Yeah,
because then I can constantly,
I can wear mittens and
constantly be arousing myself.
And no one knows.
Just wearing mittens.
And I'm just constantly in
a state of full arousal,
but my hands are cold.
Also, if they were functioning,
if they were lactating nipples,
you'd, you'd be able to have
a little bit
of sustenance wouldn't you?
Yes.
So you'd have a sip of black coffee
and then yeah.
Yeah, you'd be a grown very famous,
six foot six man sucking his thumb,
right, in public.
Then you'd go,
no, no, no it's nipples.
Don't get me wrong.
It's a nipple.
And they'd go oh, okay.
Trust me.
They'd all know
that I was the guy who
kept trying to hang himself
while masturbating.
So in the hierarchy
of embarrassing things I'm doing,
this is not.
Yeah,
doesn't come close.
There's a nice one.
If at time traveler comes to your door
from twenty-five years in the future
and you're allowed to
ask him one question,
which I thought was really,
that was really good as well.
What would you ask him?
I would say,
how was I murdered?
You know,
I would want to know
because I know someone's gonna kill me.
It's inevitable.
I would say,
and I might even be more specific
and say, how did Ricky Gervais murder me?
Yeah, yeah.
Well, what Ricky did was really clever.
It was the old collapsing wardrobe trick.
Colombo worked it out straight away.
I get a lot of cats and dogs too
as you know,
obviously that's what social media's for.
And I like the cats and dogs,
they ask questions from their perspective.
There's one, there's one dog called Bella,
who's a whippet,
that asks me questions.
And one of the questions was,
I see you've won a lot of awards,
but have you ever found
a really good stick
and taken it all
the way home?
Who's to say
what's the bigger accomplishment,
who's to say?
Yeah, exactly, Yeah.